All Things Considered the feature in
this movie look pretty sweet you
definitely said that ghosts in the
shelves so ghost in the shell' is a
live-action adaptation of the Japanese
anime from 1995 I don't know much about
all I know about ghost in the shell' is
the first PlayStation official
PlayStation Magazine that they used to
take the demo discs from have that cover
and it's stuck out in my mind as a
teenage boy I don't know why it would in
ghost in the shell' in this future a lot
of people have embraced technology and
enhancements if you lived in this world
odds would be everyone you know is
somehow cybernetically enhanced give it
arm eyeballs bladder control whatever
however Scarlett Johansson's character
is the first of her kind because they
have taken a human brain and put it in
an entirely synthetic body blurring the
lines of what is life what is a soul so
now she takes out scumbags for this
organization and when new threats arise
she's got to get on the case really I
wasn't on the ghost in the shell' movie
train for a while because none of the
trailers really grabbed me then they
released this five minute clip if we're
going through this window and just
wrecking I was like actually I was
pretty cool in five minutes of footage
you can kind of engross yourself from
the world a little more kind of see
where the world is coming from see what
scar let your hands as characters all
about I really did dig it and to that
point this world is actually a really
cool world visually speaking this movies
pretty mind-blowing few times it's not
like I get it got a blast a lot of your
budget on some other wasn't seen in
particularly she's running from this
thing it's just like hop hop hop go and
really fast those like that does look
like a lot of CGI I've seen in 2005 rest
of it the great just visually speaking
it looks like something from anime this
movie nails the world conceptual a world
where people have mods in their brains
and they can look talked with people
without using their vocal cords because
that computer chips linked to that
computer in their brain really that's
the golden egg for shit-talk right there
that's pretty much what people use it
for anyway so the world as you see it
and this movie in concept of this cyborg
that's a human brain inside a synthetic
body and questioning do I have a soul am
I just a machine like these other
machines in this world am i different
I'm not really sure that's interesting
in concept execution wise though the
movies pretty long boring drawn-out dull
slow choppy sloppy a lot of things
working against this movie
- bummer Randy this movie probably could
have benefited from being a series on
Netflix or HBO something with a higher
budget would probably have to be HBO and
I imagine that scenario was in talks at
the table when they were talking about
how to make ghosts in the show we just
look at the budget of this age look at
the worlds like we can't do that on TV
sorry it's gonna be a theatrically
released film and it's gonna feel like
it probably should have been a season of
TV Scarlett Johansson was fine she
didn't stick out in any way shape it's
not like I was like oh that could only
be Scarlett Johansson I feel ladies
probably could have played that role
this is the case with a lot of people in
movies very few times it's like that is
just meant for that actor I say the
movie feels like a season in television
because in terms of the villain it
starts out with one villain and then
there's another villain and the first
villain was way cooler and second
villain in fact first villain I really
liked a lot I was like Max Headroom has
never been cooler I called Max Headroom
because he talks like Max Headroom
he's like tweaking out and twitching
when he's talking he's like it was her
self-defense he was actually by far my
favorite part in the movie didn't him
for what he just kind of wraps up is
like alright now we're on to other
less interesting there are a few
parts especially when it just grinds
down to slow-mo for no reason whatsoever
I was like I feel like they're doing
that cuz like that's a moment that's
completely taken from the anime and you
can kind of have them side by side when
it's all in slow-mo and it'll be fun for
an editor to do and put on YouTube like
there are a couple of parts this movie
tries to hit you with the fields and
again conceptually it should have but
execution-wise it just didn't I was like
yeah I did I don't care the movie can't
just be all action action action for
something like this you do need those
deeper meanings you do need the
emotional gravity however it just
doesn't let Han guys in the end ghost in
the shell' looked great like if there's
a visual art book for this movie it'd
probably be worth it to get it the movie
has a great concept great concept of
characters or the execution and all
those points just doesn't stick the
movie can't thrive off a concept it has
to thrive off of execution of concept if
you're a fan of the anime you might be
like no this is total fanservice I love
this and I hope so but as someone who
isn't a fan of the animation didn't see
the animation I feel like you might feel
like you're in a car full of people who
are all in on this private joke and
they're all laughing and having a good
time you're like i-i-i don't know the
private joke i don't know if this movie
does the anime justice i can only base
the movie on what I saw tonight ghost in
the shell' look great but it'd probably
be a better time if I were drunk yeah
Barty people didn't like Blade Runner
when it first came out maybe it's like
that alright guys so goostin the show
the movie have you seen it what did you
think about it or did you see the
animation
do you like the animation better than
the movie this movie live up to the
animation for you whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]